[Musique]
on n'a jamais autant ri sur les réseaux
sociaux
un humour qui vire parfois à l'humour
noir comme sur cette parodie le pastiche
de roman photo
est ce qu'il y à un docteur je suis
docteur qu'est ce qu'il y a il a fait
une crise cardiaque je suis docteur en
philosophie il va mourir
on va tous mourir là je n'ai pas très
bien fait mais vous l'avez lu en même
temps parodie de philosophes ou des
bulletins météo qu'il faut dire nous
servent assez peu en ce moment avec par
exemple ce ce petite blague un nombre
d'enfants de ressentis 14 et oui les
enfants pèsent à certains parfois le
conjoint aussi qui compte top 14 qui
pèse comme 14
exemple avec cette vidéo qui a
énormément circuler c'est un des plus
gros buzz on regarde où on revoit un
extrait vient de regarder love actually
ma copine et du coup ça va donner une
petite idée parce que là ça fait
maintenant une semaine qu'on est enfermé
tous les deux un appartement et pour
être tout à fait honnête j'avais peur
que ce soit compliqué mais j'ai de la
chance parce que la cohabitation se
passe bien voilà on arrive tous les deux
à s'occuper
et puis surtout le plus important dans
un couple enfermé
on arrive à trouver notre petit zones
d'intimité et ça je trouve que c'est
plutôt agréable
voilà on ne se prend pas du tout la tête
cette fête c'est quand même sympa aussi
et puis là où j'ai de la chance c'est
qu'elle adore cuisiner
elle a une spécialité ce sont les crêpes
voilà qu'elle réussit particulièrement
bien on fait plein de trucs tous les
deux on regarde des films
j'espère que vous ça va tout simplement
et comme dit le oui là c'est un youtuber
connus et reconnus comme villa mais
beaucoup de français lambda comme on dit
se mettent aussi à faire des blagues
toute la longueur de journée alors dany
bertrand vous êtes avec nous s'est mis
log attitré de l'émission devant votre
bibliothèque
bravo vous avez respecté la consigne
bonjour denis
bonjour alors pourquoi autant de blague
pourquoi at on besoin de rêver de faire
rire sur les réseaux sociaux
je crois d'abord le fait de le phénomène
est spectaculaire vire depuis depuis le
confinant en france et pour sans doute
ailleurs aussi je dirais que l'humour a
toujours particulier avec la certitude
l'inquiétude l'oppression la menace
l'angoissent leur la relation avec le
tragique suscite l'humour comme une
sorte de conjuration pour essayer de
dépasser l'oppression et réaffirmer son
identité sa capacité de s'exprimer
dominer la situation donc louise un
coucou je suis là quoi j'existe j'existe
je me réaffirme oui je sais je voudrais
adresser oppressés par la maladie et le
confinement mais j'existe alors je
disais ce que cet humour était assez
noir au début vous allez me dire
l'humour est sûre vous souvent noir vous
qui m'ont envoyé je le dis en
pratiquement tous les jours depuis le
début du confinement
les vidéos qui vous inspirent les
blagues qui vous inspirent est ce que
vous pouvez les analyses et nous dire
dans quel registre elles sont toutes ses
blagues mais je dirais je dirais d'abord
que de lui
repose comme une sorte de principe sur
un renversement
c'est le renversement des valeurs on dit
on dit noir ont dit blanc pour exprimer
noir passé en général d'une façon très
générale et ce sans ce cul par dessus
tête en quelque sorte s'exprime par des
transgressions et le plaisir de l'humour
consiste à reconnaître les règles les
lois les principes les habitudes les
valeurs qui sont transgressées
transgression la grande la grande
transgression torture sur une loi aussi
naturel que l'amour maternel
je crois que le plaisir de l'humour
c'est de reconnaître que l'amour
maternel peut être très très violemment
transgresser voilà l'amour des enfants à
et revenir de l'avortement et alors il
ya une vidéo qui illustre parfaitement
ce que vous venez d'exprimer denis c'est
une vidéo là aussi qu'il ya énormément
circuler un des top des tops buzz pour
parler un peu triviale bord depuis le
début du confinement beaucoup temps je
suis dit ce message s'adresse à tous les
professeurs du xiii école et maître
nicole merci merci pour tout qu est ce
que vous avez au quotidien tenez pas
compte
je suis désolé j'ai créé un monstre il y
avait mis dix ans aux plus grands va pas
sans français passeront 0 jerry l'egypte
en cauchemar web
la preuve tous envoyé l'exercice de
frites
vous êtes des héros
aulas a remis en cause l'amour des
enfants
ça remet aussi en question le désamour
des profs ils deviennent les vrais aulas
dans cette vidéo
oui tous les renversements on les voit
dans l'excès dans dans la dimension de
la farce dans la transformation de
l'enfant j'ai fabriqué un monstre et et
dans la relation avec le propre au point
qu'on peut se demander si cette vidéo
n'a pas été fabriqué par une prof elle
même qui peut d'une manière ironique
mettre en scène sa propre situation face
aux enfants est là et la transpose des
on avait en miroir inverse en quelque
sorte dans la figure de la mère
elle-même
hélas hélas c'est de l'ironie aussi
jadis coup promotionnel ironique ou l ap
la promotion et la promotion du prof en
déco décombres à tous et il faut dire
d'ailleurs que ce thème de l'amour des
enfants qu'on remet en question le thème
des enfants est le premier thème de
partage avec ses vidéos et ses extraits
aussi ces petits visuels où les parents
se tournent en dérision enfants à vendre
comme une annonce immobilière ou alors
cet échange maman est-ce que j'ai été
adoptée question pose souvent les
enfants pas encore on vient juste de
mettre les annonces répond la mère ou
alors cette maman qui se trompe sur deux
sur le prénom de son enfant
il ya beaucoup de romans photos
d'ailleurs denis oui oui le genre du
roman photo est très très intéressant
dans le com comment comme on l'a vu
d'ailleurs dans dans la chaîne inaugural
que vu que vous nous avez montré du
procès du docteur philosophe je crois
que c'est le roman photo est très
intéressant parce que justement il y là
il incarne dans la forme le renversement
c'est à dire qu'il permet de mettre en
scène une situation dramatique
à travers des images qui sont totalement
inexpressive des visages sont son
placide in esprit inexpressif et c'est
le propre des romans photos alors que
les sentiments qui sont supposés être
vécus sont au contraire exacerbé et donc
le le contraste entre ces deux formes de
l'expression une expression
créer l'effet d'humour parce qu'on
reconnaît là dedans la transgression de
la règle
oui situation de notre banalité comme ça
de situation chez nous enfermer et bien
on vit un événement dramatique
paroxystique j'en rajoute un peu alors
la politique continue d'inspirer aussi
ça tombe bien pour nous avec cette image
très partagés d'emmanuel macro très très
légèrement vieilli un qui annonce
mes chers compatriotes vous pouvez
maintenant sortir alors denis là on
n'est pas dans la transgression d'une
règle on est dans quoi bon on est on est
on est donc on est dans une
transgression du même montant du crédit
dans un renversement qui qui qui passe
par une déformation et nota une double
des formations d'une part la déformation
de l'âge du jeune ou vieux alors que le
président macron avait précisément bâti
la valeur dont quelque sorte de sa
propre de son avènement de au sommet de
la politique française par la jeunesse
et donc le voici devenu vieille presque
vieillard d'une ça veut dire aussi qu'il
reste au pouvoir très longtemps qu'ils
gardent le pouvoir très longtemps donc
c'est une liée aussi le deuxième niveau
sakassou du temps c'est le temps qui lui
échappe
c'est l'effet comique vient de la
perception que l'on a de cette durée une
cinquantaine d'années tous deux de
confinement et et pour le maître des
horloges qui revendiquait être en se
disant je resterai le maître des
horloges
c'est à dire je la mette j'aurai la
maîtrise du temps je voulais qu'il
appert voilà et nous nous restons
maîtres des horloges puisque nous sommes
dans les conditions du direct alors
beaucoup de partage aussi c'est le
deuxième grand thème de partage après
les enfants les masques avec par exemple
ce zorro ans qui se retrouve avoir mis
son masque à l'envers alors là qu'est ce
qui se passe on se moque de qui il a
deux euros déjà déjà le motif du masque
est tout à fait est une mine véritable
mine comique est ici ici ce qui se passe
c'est que le héros est transformé en
personnage ridicule
donc c'est le renversement du rôle du
héros emblématique qu'est zorro en
personnage un peu grotesque qui en plus
se fâchent comme
caractériel jeter cul par dessus tête
même les héros du monde d'avant ne sont
plus des héros quoi ils ont tout faux
alors cela dit vous ridiculise les héros
mythique mais on se ridiculise aussi
soit ma main quand je dis on c'est les
français qui se met en scène dans des
vidéos exemple avec celle ci que j'aime
beaucoup
j'ai entendu aux infos ils disent que
pendant confinement il vaut mieux aussi
possible remplacer le verre d'alcool par
un pot de yaourt
bon ok pas bien compris mais à moi je
fais ce qu'on me dit ces dociles et sur
les conséquences
absurde du confinement il ya aussi cette
équipe de foot a légèrement transformé à
l'issue de la période
ou alors celle ci là je vais faire une
petite révélation c'est votre blague
préférée denis à force de me laver les
mains j'ai découvert une épreuve du bac
d'histoire de 1981 alors qu'est-ce qui
est ce qui fait rire là et pourquoi pas
aussi on voit bien ce qui fait rire mais
pourquoi elle saute en temps partagé
pendant cette période ce registre
d'abord d'abord la mise en scène de ces
trois de ces trois extraits que vous
prouviez de voir celle du corps donc le
l'objet du renversement
c'est le corps lui-même et c'est le
corps à la salle le corps chair qui
devront aussi c'est le corpo de la main
est juste un mot sur 7 sur cette main je
trouve ça en effet tout à fait
remarquable parce que c'est l'histoire
du palimpseste
mais le manager et le texte qui sous le
texte qu'il sous le texte
et là et là on a on a eu le paradoxe le
renversement du lavage des mains le
lavage des mains quelques grands motifs
aujourd'hui c'est une seule nettoyé par
sa quantité d'étoilés c'est pour effacer
les tâches et voici que au contraire le
lavage des mains fait réapparaître une
tâche enfouis dans la peau sous la peau
et la tâche ce n'est pas seulement la
trace de l'antisèche c'est la tâche
morale qui s'expriment placer le péché
originel
on se réveille on se réveille c'est très
amusant tout se révèle alors donné il
nous reste là je n'ai pas d'anti
sachions même à une minute pour conclure
donc ce registre d autodérision
personnelle et collective connaît un
immense succès on l'a vu avec ces
exemples depuis le début du confinement
pourquoi est-ce à dire qu'on se trouve
complètement idiot
individuellement et collectivement en
mode confiné je crois que l'humour
franchi une grande étape lorsqu'il
parvient à l'autodérision
lorsqu'on devient soi même le sujet de
sa de de son propre rire et et c'est
probablement avec l'autodérision que
l'humour voisine le mieux avec la
catastrophe c'est le monde lorsque le
monde parce qu par dessus tête et se
rentre dans un désordre terrible que
justement cette image c'est évidemment
le récit qui a de soul le type et amauri
dick et je crois que cette manière cette
manière de deux sortes de cette forme de
l'autodérision a pour effet de
reconstituer sa propre identité de dire
'voilà j'existe je me réaffirme voilà le
monde est cul par dessus tête mais nous
réaffirmons notre identité merci
beaucoup
denis bertrand alors comme on est
tranquillement la au calme dans notre
salon n'est ce pas on va en profiter
pour aller rejoindre benjamin grange
pour la suite de ce hashtag sur canapé
merci données merci beaucoup au revoir
benjamin grand jeu bonjour alors vous
vous n'êtes pas dans votre bibliothèque
de voir un joli tableau on va dire que
ça passe on accepte ses conçoit alors
avec denis bertrand on a commenté les
blagues sous un angle sémiologique qui
circulait sur les réseaux sociaux en
cette période de confinement est ce que
vous pouvez nous donner une appréciation
du volume de ses blagues est-ce que ça
atteint d ampleur inédite
alors oui le phénomène est évidemment
très important mais il est très
compliqué à quantifier parce que c'est
très difficile d'arriver à identifier ce
qui relève de l'humour que ce soit par
la requête ou ne serait ce que par
l'intelligence artificielle pas de
l'intelligence artificielle
voilà pour vous donner pour vous donner
l'ampleur du phénomène ne serait-ce que
l'expression morte de rire qui serait
adossé à une blague doit quelque chose
d' humour comment dire synthétiser sous
l'acronyme lol c'était presque 48
millions de messages non depuis le 10
mars
si je ne rabats prononce le terme humour
sans qu'un million de citations et les
mots-clés humour et confinement c'est
encore 31 mentions vous voyez l'ampleur
de ce que ça de ce que ça représente
aujourd'hui ça t'a beaucoup à votre
courbe c'est ce calme entre à elle
montre en fait
l'ampleur de ce phénomène là avec un
certain nombre de pics
le premier pic il est aux alentours du
18 mars en fait à partir de ce moment là
on commence à évoquer le confinement et
les effets sur notre perception du temps
et donc c'est là qu'on voit des images
se propage et ouvrir le président macron
avant le président m'a conquis avis qui
a terriblement vieilli vingt ans après
pour montrer qu'on a commenté avec
dernier confirmant la vente de menthe
on passe déjà dans la
professionnalisation de l'humour c'est
là qu'il ya des vidéos professionnelles
iata m'vila que vous avez montré
précédemment
et donc c'est là que le cynisme et
l'humour noir commence à se généraliser
des sujets des couples dans confinement
les sujets liés aux enfants avec ces
images d'enfants à vendre et de et de
comment dire et d'adoption voilà tout
cet humour noir commencent à se faire
sentir correctement et puis on a un
dernier pic
on a un dernier pic créativité et donc
qui vient de la généraliser
en fait des parodies des films des
champions c'est adele c'est le masque
deux ou les trois grands les trois
contents et comment ça circule alors
tout c'est tout ses blagues sur les
réseaux sociaux
par quel mode ça se propage alors
d'abord il ya tellement d'amour
l'humour y dira sans doute de tout on
met dans la circonstance ça prend
comment dire une forme particulière
d'abord parce que la légèreté deux
associés l'humour est la bienvenue face
à la gravité de la crise sanitaire
et donc c'est une forme de soupape de
décompression disponibles directement
sur son téléphone et donc ça facilite en
fait le seul truc qu'on a avec soin en
ce moment la deuxième chose c'est que
les humoristes
il bénéficie d'un certain crédit
d'authenticité on ne peut pas les
soupçonner d'être d'être moraliste
d'avoir des intérêts cachés
et puis enfin et puis enfin l'humour
reste aussi une bonne
une bonne manière de prendre de la
distance puis de maintenir le lien ça
s'échange sas échanges avec ses amis
donc les vidéos elles se virilise par
tous les moyens et donc avec les amis ça
veut dire que ça circule plus sur les
boucles privée que sur twitter par
exemple qui est un peu détrôné las alors
sa vie réalise sur les réseaux sociaux
classiques facebook
la fréquentation de facebook augmenté de
37%
mais sa vie réalise aussi pas mal sûr
voilà toutes les boucles c'est à dire
les messages et instantanée et whatsapp
en particulier quelques chiffres qui
vont vous donner en fait la manière dont
ça se propage
l'utilisation de facebook à deux doigts
de sap augmenté de 27% dans les premiers
temps de l'épidémie s'est passé à 41% à
la deuxième semaine et pour les pays les
plus comment dire les plus avancés dans
la crise c'est presque 51 % de
croissance d'utilisation plus de
whatsapp évidemment l'humour ça ça
contribue à ça c'est donc une manière
finalement de rester ensemble c'est ça
c'est de prolonger de faire les dîners
de famille on a fait beaucoup beaucoup
d' apéros zuma c'est une manière de
rester en famille malgré le confinement
c'est ça aussi l'exact mot c'est une
manière d'entretenir le lien ne
indépendamment de la distance
on continue à rire ensemble et bagneux
aussi nous gardons le lien maj hama
malgré la distance
à très bientôt et puis est très bientôt
à tous pour une nouveau numéro de
hashtag sur canapé
mais ça
non